Haba da bee, badip bap!
Boing! *laughing*
Okay. Hang on, wait- AAH! *laughing* Oh, fucking hell, god dammit, that actually spooped me!
*santa voice* Deauh! Deaugh!
Kiddies!? Stop break-dancing for one goddamn second!
Your twerk obsession is not welcome here!
Tip! Don't get hit! What a great tip!
Justin Bieber! I dunno what this me-
OOOOH! OOoooOh god!
AAAAAAAH! Oh shi- *laughing* Ooooh, god dammit!
Alright, I had no idea what you were talkin' about.
HUP!
Wooooah boy! AaaaaaAAH!
Alright. We're doin' fine, doin' fine, doin' fine, doin' fine-
WOOOOW!
Hey!
I got a secret zone!! :D
Theif 5!
You theif! And your purpose token!
Purpose token? This one- Oh, it is a click.
Rate... 5!
Got it! I'll be-
Oh-hoh!
I'll pl- I'll play your game!
Y- You
You god dammit!
You rogue! Aaaah!
Hoooo! *laughing*
*still laughing* yeeaaah!
Pogo Ninja! Wow, a lotta pogos and... a lotta 'poons this week!
Habooshky!
Aaaagh! *laughing* Right in the back of my neck- Oh come on!
*laughing* You played yo-yo with my skull!
HAH!
I yumped!
I yump- Woooah eeeey! WoooOOOOoW!
That last one got me! It had some oomph!
~Peehdooh!~ AAHAHA! You bent me in half!
BOINK! Okay!
Shwoopty!
Shwanko!
Why does that keep happening?
*laughing* Ohohohoho! Gah- oh god dammit!
I dunno wha- AAAAGH! Fuck! Whelp!
Alright, that's cool.
AH! *laughing* It went up my butt and out my head!
Or did I see that wrong but it l-
Oh, god! What a compromising position!
Ah, shit! God damn- AAGH!
Yumping!
Wooaaow! OOH!
YES!! I'll take it!
I'm not in as many pieces as I was in the last- whhuuut.
Oh, *laughing* I thought that was something that killed me.
Just dooooo it!
I- I'll do it! I'll do it!
Fuck dat dragon!
Fuck dat dragon right in its dragon butt!
uugh.
Okay! Maybe not fuck dat dragon right in its dragon butt!
Fuck dat dragon oh-so-tenderly!
That dragon is mean!
I gotta somehow- SOMEHOW,
Get away from this dragon.
Hey! Hey buddy! Woooah!
Ooo, you're gettin jiggly on me!
Ooh, you gettin jiggly!
Oh, you so angwey!
HAH! Oh, this ain't gonna end good.
AH! Oh, I got minced!
You dragon cock!
You dragon bitch!!
You dragon sack of shit!
You dragon! More like draggin' my balls across...ya FACE!
BIATCH!
*old man voice* Oooh! Oh god! AAAH!
Somehow I'm still alive!
AH! These are some huge bottles!
I dunno about this one!
Eh. Okay. Alright. Okay! Alright! Okay!
Ah. NO! AAAAGH!
AGGH GOD, what the hell happened!?
WHY?! HOW AND WHY AND HOW AND WHY?!?!?
Ehhhh~
Oh yeah
These are some huge bottl- Oh jesus.
Oh, Oh l- OHH OHH OHH
Good thing I can FLYYYY!
aAHHHH It didn't help!
Ahhh *laughing* it didn't help at all!
Okay, a, okay, okay, okay
okaY, OKAY, OKAY, AHHH
AHHHH
YES, alright, good!
I think I pooped my helmet out my dick,
but it alright!
Try to stoOOOOOOOOOP!
I SAAAAAAAAAY!
Impossible, my left nUUuut.
Pogo fight.
What is it, frickin' POGO WEEK?
HA-BUN-SHKEY!
Fuck off with you!
I'm gon get cha.
HYEAAHHH!
Right in your goocher!
Right in your fraboocher!
Hope you..die.
Again-
HUUUAH!
Zombie king?
I'll take your spear in my teeth,
and I'll shove it up your bum!
HABOOSKEY!
Man hunter?
MAN HUNTER?
Hohh, not a very good man hunter if you ask me!
OH NO! A drunk kid!!
Don't drink, children!
Or else you apparently die!
Spring challenge!
Welp, okay then.
*laughing* Wohohoho, that was a little deviously close.
Alright, hang on...
HAAAAAH!
AAAAGGH, shit, I dunno what happened, but death came quick!
Ah, whatever! I don't need your bomb!
I don't need your sh-awwwww
I don't need your bomb! I've got the winning recipe right here..
AAAAAAH!
It's getting rid of this awful pogo!
And w-AAAAH fuck.
Ahhh, jeez!
You can stop any day now!
I'd be fine with that...
*lisping* Dis ish imposhible!
HOH-
Ah fuck! What the fuck happened!
I don't even know!
The sewerage!
Okay!
Why is we down in sew- yonder sewer?
Am I supposed to av-ooooh AAAAAAAAH!
Ahhg- Uuuuhg I stepped in shit!
Now I smell bad *laughing*
Not really death, but a bad punishment, that's for sure!
Heeeeh~
Okay.
Ehhhh~
Alright!
Uh!
This is a weird sewer layout!
But I understand it!
That wall seems weak...
Well! I'll bash it with all my inhibitions!
That way it will be equally weak!
This wall seems stronger, I need to find a hammer.
You mean, like my thick skull?
Where am i gonna find a hamrar?
oooOOOOH!
Click???
Don't mind if I dOOOooo~
Okay, so I got a hamrar!
What is that gonna do for maaaa?
Im gon get cha,
I'm gon get cha!
HAH!
Broke you! Just like all of my willpower when my-
wife left me. :'(
AWWWWH!
I shoulda had m'helmet!
Spike fall ranks!
♪ AAANND HERE WE GOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO- ♪
♪ Here we GOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO- ♪
♪ HERE WE GOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO ♪
ow.
HERE WE guuuuhhh~
ehh?
ehhH?
AAAHHH?
YEEAHH??
HAAAAH!
'Poon Run Epic!
No I dunno how epic most of these- woah, those are different 'poons!
Well!
I survived that- Oh god there's more!
Oh no!
Me and my son just wanna live!
Oh god!
OH GOD NO!
OH IT'S TOO FAST!
AHHAHAah
Obstacle Course!
Beige
Because that's the most interesting of colors!
You can't beat me!
I'm the gingerbread....fucker.
I dunno
Night Bike Club!
Oh!
This is actually nice!
I-I guess??
I have a funny feeling it's going to end in horrible horrible ways!
But for now!
I-It's downright pleasant!
Old man!
You're doing such lovely cartwheels! It's amazing!
Oh- WOAAOOH!
Oh- he was just having fun!
He was just doing cartwheels and I killed him!
And now we've conglomerated into some horrifying machine?
Of what I can only assume will be dea-IT'S DEATH.
IT'S DEATH!
OH GOD IT'S DEATH!
Oh god, what have I done!?
Troll map demo!
Ooaaahhhooooh- shesh nehg eeh I dun wanner naked
I D- WAAAAAAAH.
OOOOKAY.
I DIDN'T WANT 'EM NAKED!
Don't jump!
Harpuns!
What happens if i jump?
Ooooh...
*laughing* Hiii okay alright
Aahh, it was scary!
Oh, hello.
You've dropped me, shit.
Token???
Oh boy!
I'll go for a-
AAAAH SHIT!
AHHHHHHHH!
THEY'RE IN MY GRUNDLE!
Oh, I'm still alive!
So now, we don't go for the token.
Which is obviously still true!
Don't forget, the token.
Oh, ah shit.
Ahhh, goddammit.
Bottle run??
Oh okay.
Goddammit.
Ah shit!
Ah goddammit!
When's it gonna end?
Agh- oh, goddammit!
Oh- ah- final!
Kill 'em! Ah, shit!
AHH GODDAMMIT!
WHERE ARE WE GOING NOW!?
Fuck.
This has been Happy Wheels Highlights!
Thanks for watching!
If you wanna see more Happy Wheels -right now-
Check the description or click the annotation for the full Happy Wheels playlist!
And if you want to see more Happy Wheels in the future,
please click the like button to let me know!
Thanks again, everyone,
and as always,
I will see you!
In the next video.
BUH-BYE!
♪♪♪